the most shocking playoffs in memory
continue into the second round yes these
are the playoffs gone absolutely crazy
like two straight weeks of games there
is no telling how often this bad boy
will go on tonight but I can tell you
one thing I will be ready well Mike said
before the game that he would be ready
for the cannon
that doesn't look like you're ready nor
tops Mike you were scared to death right
correct me if I'm wrong
silence is golden earlier this afternoon
David's apart and set the tone playfully
imitating the coaching staff even acting
out what a coach's challenge might look
like if we have one here tonight but it
was moments after that when we saw what
a real head coach looks like prior to a
game John Tortorella calm composed and
focused at least for now
Shane 3 ready for takeoff that's good
there look at what John Tortorella as he
arrived in all of the haze in darkness
not every entry can be perfect and with
a sense of humor he approaches the start
of game number four
we know Abuna is Wella the guys showed
and
looked like he might and its prior
the brass key hero
you should hear him down here he's
talking to the players she's talking all
the time he's in heat yeah he's into it
he's just talking to me right now he's
raving alone and the playoffs things
change so quickly expect the unexpected
oh my god like that right there
Kentucky Hamill they cried the final
curtis back when t is that not any
credit and expect the unexpected I'm
telling you he lays this hard on the net
look at the 50 something but get on if
you get me beat the breakout to Center
and dump the puck in most of malfunction
for Bob oh boy and maybe cut look at
that look at those eyes
my heart stopped watching this you see
this bucket lands on edge and look at it
just go oh man to the left that's a
nightmare but good recovery there by Bob
Roth ski he argued the whole way to the
Box didn't wake up another power play
for the Avalanche coming up and
obviously the big man doesn't like being
in the penalty box wants to not let us
see him that's him behind his stick the
live look in the pitch for bread birds
Draco saying it went off the Sagan way
that's straight up and over
the ice there's at least two have to be
brother and sister folks and Asus just
like the to plot upon the ice looks like
me when I'm on the airplane fighting for
that elbow kept it away from Spezza
Gutterson up the middle looking for
Swartz puck deflected out of play
Ezekiel Elliott helping the young man I
got it with a partner yeah it's a selfie
it's good I don't make him feel better
oh yeah that's awesome
he'll dig into the corner Spencer trying
to pull it off for Tuesday drops Lyndell
down Lyndell dives Lyndell dice again
close the box for being Greg Louganis
and then he dives again Esalen down just
old three times what an absolute first
or two so fired up off the call hits him
again you see his head snap back I mean
it's robber for to the arena's lip from
up here he says dive dive dive
three dies inexcusable
you
if the unthinkable happens in either
goalie gets injured tonight as it
happened in Game two the Hurricanes have
an emergency backup police ready to jump
in he's 29 year old computer engineer
Spencer Williams the NC State grad even
suited up earlier this season when
Roberto Luongo went down although he
didn't actually end up going in the game
Williams plays in a local men's league
that's him actually last night playing
getting all ready his gear is in the
locker room right now ready to go but
for now he's just an interested
spectator now plays it for Filppula back
to the blue line a full circle
no bill he has a power-play goal but did
it hit the output of the mentor the
inside all the horn went off it looked
like it went in the net it looked like
Ryan pullin and put the islanders in the
lead you can see that area right there
you see where the plastic is lifted that
that's where it went
right into that little area
now the fans will sit back down there
the collective brujon from the crowd as
they watch the replay or excited at all
the SWAT handers lay it back down so far
angles one
but stick Marcelle looking for Bailey
backdoor look at the spec position of
slaving tried intercept
all the way over for burns that shot
clock by Kerfoot who lost his skate
played his blood stars watch Kirkland
he's gonna get in the lane on burns the
plates gonna pop weight out of escape
Victor Club the neutrals almost fly
to get up and get back into play but no
chance without a blade on the skates
Riley beside the Pietrangelo by Fischer
and they weren't kidding about stick
besides look out another score this
thing is going to knock the stick right
out of Ben Bishop ten
little push-off by Vince done and then
Robert Gamez posted in touch my book
bullshit fish that it on
start
the star is tied at 1 as Billington
didn't know where the putt bugs and it
bounced erecting super low and that went
off the referee and back out in front
and on a very odd play Binnington lost
his stick and the star stuck it in the
back of the net a three quarter sheet
shot on vision no prob but then he
turned it over and it's maroon he shoots
and that discombobulation went their way
unbelievable they had a great big soggy
bag of nothing going on and this is a
different game now on a nothing way
that shot clock Jones again and in close
it is no goal there were some sticks
raised by Foligno but held by rats that
put in this very close I think yeah
maybe in guys tulino was out near the
blue line and he raised his arms and
said hey and look at the conversation
Trask is having with her alley right
there if I know a pup went in I might
say oh boy let's see if we get away with
it with 927 to go in the third
attendee Panera's Jones with a shot that
was
went up into the knitting nobody's side
buckner still up for grabs at the net
Kelly from Erin gets the goal but that
pump goes out of play and hit the netic
it did and that's what Bergeron stopped
right there you can see the white food
just behind but nobody saw and nothing
can be done about it
Wow what a break I didn't know what
happened I didn't see a hit from that if
I saw it then I would have probably time
to stick some chasing the Rex but
probably better that I did see Nico
Ratna may just have missed on his best
scoring chance of the night the
teammates and opposing players marvel at
his puck handling skills where's that
come from well try the Scandinavian game
of four bolts played with short sticks
that have ripple blades to premium on
handling the bouncing ball with the
skill rentman played the sport four or
five times a week and an organized
league from 5 to 15 years of age so this
is where his soft hands come from but
they just were not soft enough on that
last chance date pretty cool you know
it's a game and Zuccarello has been
great like that too I keep turning
around told me his coach world for one
we're having fun relax at one point in
the second period
did you relax after Matt said that I do
he has it like such a like a pleasant
smile on that mic yeah you're right
after yesterday when Martin looked left
practice was that a setback necessarily
I don't expect him to not play but you
know what I'm more practice right he's
what we talking about practice man what
are we talking about practice so that
you'll be back here for Game seven what
we will what gives you the confidence
that because we will
the Boston Bruins 3 the Columbus Blue
Jackets nothing and in the series four
games to two this is as far as this
franchise has ever been is there a sense
of accomplishment for you don't even go
there does it no don't even go there
with me I'm not gonna listen to that
about an accomplished man you get to the
second I don't you want to listen to her
reaches over the boards to pick it up
Lovejoy loses his glove over the boards
it negates enticing did you imagine if
that had an effect on an icing ball
faceoff in a game seven man oh man
whose have the puck Thomas off the wall
shoots
put the city on his shoulders any sense
under the
what can you say about the way your
group handle the next three games and
ultimately advancing to the conference
final pretty good job what do you make
of the opportunity to lies ahead of you
it's been fun so I see where this is
going here I'll ask you one more about
your line
what kind of zone are you three in we're
good thanks
well that was worth the gym Foucault now
a chance for Bailey his shot Josh Bailey
when you come in you just score a big
goal and tied up and you've passed the
goalie on the top of his mouth yeah
they're not gonna appreciate it I'm sure
Macklin he didn't appreciate it either
she want to rattle the pots and pans a
little bit huh
five to win in a four-game sweep of the
New York Islanders